hello I'm Felipe Hoffa and today I'm in
Melbourne Australia to meet my good
friends at shine solutions with Graham
poly we've done many challenges like
processing 30 terabytes of data will be
queried all running Hadoop jobs while in
the Train thanks to that approach but
today we want to see how much data we
can process with dataflow before
reaching the city follow me I'm here
with Ram poly from shine solution and
I'm so glad to see you again it's been a
while two years two years
I remember within the 30 terabytes
challenge with the query yeah
then you queried all this data while on
we data probe while on the train yeah in
17 minutes we spoon up a data processor
Hadoop spark and I did it in the 17
minutes on the train nice and today
we're going to jump from Hadoop data
flow data flow yes we're gonna read lots
of data and try and get the cluster up
and running and the pipeline finished by
the time we hit the city lattice pretty
cool but by the way you've been doing a
lot of great stuff other than this
calendar yeah a lot happened in the last
two years since we've seen each other so
I'm an official Google developer expert
named gde congratulations thank you very
much for Google a platform the only one
in Australia nice cooked and honor and
we've got the new Sydney region there
for Google cloud platform so that's
super news for us
yeah and also showing her a new office
up in Sydney which is nice I should
check that one out so let's go play
Talent and then we will discuss all what
you're doing with your customers okay so
we're gonna run a simple pipeline while
on the tram before we hit the city and
Mowgli okay will be completed by the
phone
pretty close to the city so I better
kick it off I'm gonna kick it off my
development environments we're gonna
have a look at the code as well how it's
working but I'm gonna get it started
perfect so this pipeline is gonna read
ten point six billion records from
Google Cloud storage
nice gonna run them through a
transformation a pardhu and then it's
going to write the results to be query
for River analysis somewhat simulates
what we do in production for our
customers now how many files is if it's
a few thousand a few thousand files then
we can be known
it's about half a terabyte mm-hmm yeah
so the beauty of this is I only have to
write about 20 lines of code I'm using
the Java SDK dorota SDKs for Windows you
have the Python one yeah I chose about
20 lines of code but all the
infrastructure is split up for me I
don't care about any of the
infrastructure you guys worry about that
stuff I don't have doing that yes with
20 lines of code you are fairly dataflow
prefer to read the files correct uh-huh
then transform so I'm looking for a
certain word in each title so the data
that we're using is a sample from
Wikipedia and so it's got all the page
views from this is what they were
allergic you want to run yeah I'm
looking for Melbourne in the title
because we're in beautiful Dover nice
and then at the end we do a write to
bigquery right to be quiet
Yeah right right no not a strand right
so while I was running my tests I kind
of doing a straight right the bigquery
was taking a little bit longer than I
had hoped and the reason was dataflow is
producing a lot of files and that
bigquery then happens subsequently has
to do a low job in each of those files
in so what I do is I do a little trick I
specify without charting and I write
back to GCS a single file and then load
that in using the bigquery API
protip how is your deployment going ok
let's have a look so we can see from the
Java logs that workers have started
successfully so happy the next thing we
want to do is flick over to the Google
cloud platform console is no parking so
guru is monitoring all of your
everything the beauty of this is it
allows me to have focus on the code I
don't have to worry about any of the
infrastructure so it's like
hands-off great it allows us to do what
we want to do so if you go to the Google
cloud platform
and we jump over to data flow fingers
crossed
we're tethering off my phone remember
yeah we're not using any type of problem
we're on whether it is whether the tram
yeah so I'm kettering my phone which is
in my bag and we're spinning up a
massive cluster of Google cloud platform
so now we already in data flow here yeah
certainly the pipeline is filled
it's actually I think it's spun up to
50/50 VMs or 35 am switching data flow
did itself it demanded the metadata that
had the read amount I need more VMS in
the stack
sounder bringing them in and you can see
it's auto scaling they're able to power
how many records that we processing this
is crazy unfortunate it's spinning all
this up reprocessing 27 million records
a second a second a second you better
come we're getting closer silly where
are we
shiny remembrance so we're pretty close
we better better get cracking maybe some
City highlights too
so of course when we deploy this for our
customers we don't run it from our
development environment obviously so we
have a we've been property' for in the
process for now and we use credit
functions for a lot of okay so good yeah
and what kind of stuff are you doing for
your customers so with our customers
this is a very basic pipeline and
showing today is the basic read to
transform and right but for our
customers we apply a lot more complex
business logic and rules to the pipeline
actually multiple side inputs coming
into our data flow pipeline from the
spire of data sources transforming it
and then multiple rights at the bigquery
for further analysis by the product
teams and I can show you so exact I
would love to see one graph examples so
this is a really good example of one of
a one of our pipelines in production
this is a massive read from TCS uh-huh I
think this is maybe a hundred files
reading about a hundred million records
this is a real life sitting in GCS and
then but the beauty of this is look at
all these side inputs coming in and
enriching the data applying business
rules logic transforming that data and
then writing to multiple destinations in
big very nice and you're reading this
from a huge file a new cloud storage and
written it with bigquery pebbles
actually this one is reading from
multiple files and
storage and then writing to multiple
tables but I have an example of a
literal which is one big file read you
can see here so this is a massive read
from GCS a transform and then I don't
know twenty outputs the bigquery nice
how did you launch this process of run
every day so we've got a pretty nice
pattern that we use in production and
our customers like it as well so what we
do is we set up a Google Cloud function
listening to a bucket and when a new
file arrives that kicks the pan function
off which calls a data flow template
ritalin starts processing the data and
that's the trick to run the dataflow
pipeline has a template yes you set up
all your called
alpha-beta flow paper yeah then you can
figure from a function with whatever
reason you fire all correct already so
it's all hands off we don't maintain any
that stuff don't need it but it's
service it's all the way to seven less
yeah I have to get it how many records
have we brought us a fax eight point six
billion April six billion so far okay so
let's go back to the customers because
it's really interesting to see how
everything is out of scaling so clusters
starting up more VMs coming into the
stack to process the data but then close
the technique that there's not so much
data to process anymore dropping and
bm's every stack which saves our clients
a lot of money exactly because they're
paying by server
yeah and this one jumped all the way
back to 20 server so to begin with 20
and then went back there to turn it back
up to 20 again and then eventually the
whole customer store - that's right
before I serve less service a meal in
some steps grants autoscanning go from
but we don't determine those steps they
don't notice all that for us nice
we go back here you can see all the
pipeline instead of Rome introduction oh
these are running permanently like many
times are they all thanks to cloud
functions yet all triggering from tight
budgets and then you have the templates
that's right nice almost there almost
there
handy we're out to 9 million records now
and fine 567 cake thankfully hopefully
perfect any other deeper you have phone
for people doing stuff with better flow
and the right thing about dataflow is it
allows you to concentrate on the code
itself rather than worry about anything
infrastructure the beauty of theta flows
well it runs above batch and streaming
mode yes so you write once primitive
bastions treatment it's really helpful
so if you're not streaming real-time
data you can also use data for yeah we
did this with bats but you're also
useful for frustrating as well yeah and
we do a lot of bigquery streaming on we
mix the tools together you also need to
decide sometimes we use bigquery or do
you use better flow yes picking the best
tool for the job so the crew is great at
smashing through data and aggregating
data feels really good for pulling all
that data in transforming and sending it
the secure converter knows nice how are
we doing here we're done with them
excellent thanks for the fine
awesome so we made it back to the shine
offices on time
salads complete the challenge completed
that was pretty nice it that was a great
challenge yes how much data you process
man we processed over 10 billion records
that were in GCS at 500 gigabytes almost
half a terabyte all in under 10 minutes
using cloud dataflow in after 10 minutes
then Beatle record that's like 29
million records a second being read and
transform dibala when we were testing
while we were tethering off my mobile
phone that's pretty cool who handled all
the complexity but the beauty of it is
dataflow handle all the complexity of it
right so it's been up the worker pool
autoscale VMS we went up to 50 VMs and
then when it was finished towards our
cluster that that was pretty nice yeah
very nice
yeah so what do we do now that's a tough
question
drink a beer okay salute salute Rasta
[Music]
you